I I feel like we should start with Seth
because we all know this begins with the
the script and I know you co-wrote this
with your writing partner will Tracy can
you tell us what was sort of the initial
inspiration behind this movie well my
co-writer will was uh on this honeymoon
in Norway with his wife and he took a
boat to a restaurant on an island the
same thing didn't happen to will because
he's alive and
um and but he's actually kind of a bit
of a claustrophobe and he was kind of
freaked out by the experience of just
being on this island for four hours and
sort of entrusting his live livelihood
to these people and at one point he just
you know turned to his wife and said I
actually think this would be a cool
start germ of an idea for a movie and
Betsy for you how did this project find
its way to you and what interested you
in being a part of it
this was just a classic incoming script
from Will's agent and I read it four
years ago uh and it was obscenely well
written and McKay Adam McKay is the
producer of the film alongside me and he
he and I just devoured it
um and so hard not to do I had to stop
myself
yeah but it it was um just like nothing
we had really read before and then from
there it was about sitting down with
directors and it was certainly this
beloved script around town that had a
lot of fans and was on The Blacklist and
all that
um and so a lot of people were raising
their hand and Mark was Mark mylad who
does our show succession Mark was really
the first director that we sat down with
who had a similar version of the movie
in his head that we did in ours and he
really understood how to like capture
that kind of sense of dread and
anticipation and marry that with the
biting satire and biting humor
um and that was so important was
somebody needs to understand where the
comedy comes from for this movie and
that's a real kind of high wire act to
pull off I feel like because the tone is
really tricky
um and he did it beautifully
anything I I love this I heard that this
movie combined your two loves film and
food which are two of mine
um so is it sort of a no-brainer when
you read this script would you start
getting excited about all the things you
could do with the design and the food
yeah I mean I think food making and
filmmaking are really really similar
they're both um and and when I was a
starving filmmaker trying to make a name
for myself I worked in a lot of
restaurants
um and kind of almost fell into that
career trajectory because it was the
first time I felt like you were part of
this transient community of instant
family is creating an ephemeral
experience that's very Lush and detailed
But ultimately artificial and the minute
it's over you kind of wish that you
could go back to it and what does that
sound like it sounds like filmmaking so
um they're really really similar
experiences and the idea of being able
to combine like my two favorite things
in one was delicious
and this movie actually gets food
culture and Foodies so authentically did
that begin in the writing and the
production because I know you had you
must have had real Consultants
definitely began in the writing but then
in terms of Consultants we had an
amazing one of the most amazing chefs in
the entire universe I guess uh named
Dominique kren who has three Michelin
stars she works in San Francisco but
what's cool about Dominique is that she
doesn't make food
the way that Chef slowik makes food her
food is warmer uh Chef's food is colder
and so she actually kind of had to get
into character to create dishes that
Chef slowik would create and I think
that was a challenge that she
quite relished uh because she's she's an
artist and she wanted to try something
new and she was amazing to have on set
and then we had David Gelb who was the
creator of Chef's Table do our second
unit and so he and Chloe Weaver shot all
of the food porn shots and it was the
entire time we were trying to kind of
rip off his style and we're like let's
just get the guy who does the thing
um and so he came on after the fact and
shot all those like very dreamlike sort
of food porny shots
this is like this is like Nancy Meyer's
dream kitchen this thing is so beautiful
I want it so badly
um I'm curious if you can talk about
designing something that not only looks
phenomenal but it's actually practical
yeah
um so we're making our artificial
restaurant at the height of the Delta
Resurgence when every single restaurant
in America is trying to reopen and is
buying the highest end dutch ovens and
six tops and French fryers at the same
time that we're trying to do it for our
artificial movie so that was really
really challenging and we had to like
fight for the last fridge and fight for
the last stove and convince them like
we'll sell it back to you in six months
um but one of the things that we found
most interesting when we were
researching this because we knew we
wanted to make a fully functional
kitchen we knew authenticity was
Paramount was we went into the backs of
restaurants high and low and three star
one star McDonald's we went everywhere
we were so curious to see how every
kitchen was designed and sure enough we
discovered they're exactly the same
every kitchen is ultimately sacrificing
a square inch for just one extra table
or chair the aggregate profit of one
chair over the course of a fiscal year
in a heist takes restaurant is 300 000
per chair so if you can push one more
lineman to be elbow to Elbow with
another Chef on the line you will
because it means just one more meal that
you can serve that justifies the entire
operation's existence so that was really
interesting for us to explore and to
make to balance the difference between
something that was small enough to look
real and big enough to be practical to
actually shoot and I don't know if this
is just a restaurant thing or specific
for this movie but it feels like a
church to some degree I don't know so
bad you saw that oh yeah yeah
um you're the first person to say that
so no you're kidding no well the idea
for the kitchen for me was for for it to
be ecclesiastical I want him to feel
like a priest at a Pulpit so there's a
it's a salt box frame and there's a
giant Cross behind him and he's his
floor is built a little higher than all
the other chefs because I loved the idea
that all these Junior chefs are like
genuflecting to him so yeah I know very
much it's it's meant to feel like a
place of worship it's cultish and it's
definitely inspired by the feeling you
get in some of these kitchens where you
feel like okay this person's like a
deity and they're exalted but they're
also like you know they have a lot more
power than maybe a human being should
have
oh you've talked about this amazing cast
and it's just every role is cast so
perfectly um I want to start with Ray
fines because it's rare that you have
that combination of instant gravitas but
then also that subversive humor yeah
um I don't was he the first person cast
uh yes I mean well I know there was
there was a moment when will and I were
writing when we were writing that we
just
we just knew this this is Ray fines and
what's wonderful about him is he can be
menacing and jaunty at the same time so
the movie
it's dark but because we're riding along
with him it still stays funny and
so he's so integral to the tone we're
trying to achieve
like Anya
and the way Mark films Anya
I think is absolutely incredible in the
movie she holds down and anchors the
movie and without her I think the movie
would
yeah and uh she she's she's incredible
but she's doing with her face
uh is I think brilliant how many
giraffes do you think you went through
just one shooting oh yeah okay this one
uh we sold the outline
there was just a rough rough outline
no yeah I mean like uh I I don't know
how many drafts but I do know that
the the movie The it got more
sophisticated
as time went on it got a little it got
less it got less violent the themes that
I was talking about came out more and
more
um so that's what I'm most proud of but
like you know it was more just how do we
keep on shipping away to make it more
sophisticated to make these people more
aware of themselves and more human and
yeah they got less violent what's that
oh yeah yes the first the first draft
was more violent
um and I'm glad it got less violent I
think the less violent it got uh
I I'm sorry to repeat myself but the
more sophisticated it got and then just
the threat
of violence was more impactful than
actual violence after you after the sort
of The Gunshot and the finger slice
nothing really nothing really happens to
the diners from the staff until the very
end but at the very end they kind of
accept their fate yeah there's a couple
people who say we love you too Chef
along with the chef who are in the
restaurant because the chef has made
quite a compelling argument for why this
should happen and Ethan for you was
there a particular set or art piece
there's so much to stare at in this
movie when you're designing a space that
is a character in the film and
predominantly your sole location for the
majority of the of this of the script
how do you make that interesting how do
you keep it um layered how do you peel
them back to maintain audience interest
but also to tell you something about
characters that are Mysteries and you
don't reveal too much about them
um I couldn't have done this movie
without having done the movie room where
you're largely in a 10 by 10 by 10 box
because on that film I learned the
smaller the set the more interesting the
set the details become planets and solar
systems they're every detail in every
set can be shot as its own planet
um and so you know really when you're
approaching a movie like this especially
with a script that's so rich with
characters that are each onions that
need to be unpeeled
um the the restaurant has to be a
layered person too and so like
approaching it with the respect of every
surface and every choice having Merit
and having a narrative reason that's
really really challenging but also like
so fun when you're working with people
you trust and who up your auntie every
day uh I want to thank you all so much
for being here and thank you for a great
movie thanks thank you
[Applause]